Derek Jeter gets married Serena takes
number 22 Duncan hangs it up I'm in
dallas this is sports without balls
everyone this is market alcohol
did it get them do hey sports without
balls fans friends family you guys were
back we are back 12 weeks this is a
skype call between myself fan favorite
greatest co-host of all time Trish Suhr
ja I missed you so much thank you for
having me back I'm looking at Trish
through the power of a computer screen
she is in los angeles and i am in dallas
texas and i wish i could see what we
look like because normally when control
in the studio we both look is she the
same because we do it around the same
time of day um this time i look like i
might be going to get a job at sears
hate it Aaron looks like she's going to
be piloting a transcontinental flight at
any moment this show can go off the
rails I'm just saying I have first of
all I'm barely awake you're it's 9am
here it's seven a.m. in los angeles and
you are like up and chipper and I can't
believe you girl face of makeup too I
know I couldn't bear the thought of you
seeing me on skype looking all sad um I
rolled that about I my glasses on it I
had some sort of headset that literally
looks like I'm piloting an airplane it's
so fantastic it's like y'all I fuses on
I want to give her by eight at home the
visual she's got that headset on Mike
Howard Cosell used to wear even when he
didn't need to like you know he'd wear
it even when noise wasn't an issue he
had on that ridiculous jaunt with the
big headphones and that's what we've got
right now so Aaron's ahead this morning
and I love it um I'm just fans out there
I'm I apologize again for the two weeks
of being dark I did I did say that we
were gonna be dark for two weeks oh I'm
just so thrilled to be back and I was
too thrilled you are on the other end
thank people and exist you i miss you so
much and we have this is what kills made
it we've not been together is we've
missed some monumental moments in sports
giganto yeah most importantly in my
household the Cavs championship so
here's how this episode we'll go no idea
no
kidding I have an outline I have an
outline nobody panic out there I'm
panicking I there there has been so many
things I haven't even recorded since
like the couple days after the Cavs one
right so that we have two weeks ago no
that will be like almost three weeks ago
now yes I've been working insane our
days you we all boat we both have like
80 jobs yeah and so I haven't talked to
you personally about sports and probably
a month it's not okay yes and also these
last couple weeks I sense of dislike
crazy new work schedule and also not
having i just realized i could record on
this T on this television last night no
so I recorded the all-star game because
I had a work last night so I haven't
even watched the all-star game i just
did highlights last night so i'm excited
now because now going into olympics i
can record thank God because you're
stuck there which I care for um they
they put us in a pond like these really
awesome like long stay yes yeah I have a
why it's nicer than the place i live in
in Los Angeles so I just moved to Dallas
but I can't because the Cowboys are
right around the corner ah now I was at
target yesterday just buying all kinds
of stuff you know you need four months
of living and the amount of Dallas
paraphernalia I was like oh but I with
the city I like no I'll and you're there
in a rush town girl yeah it's um it's a
little hot oh my god in more just one
way honey yeah a lot of a lot of white
people and some some hairstyles I
wouldn't approve of oh I love I mean
hair watchin in Dallas really should be
some kind of an event like when we have
to watch national food eating
competitions when you know sports are
slow like the fourth of July I would
like them to do the big big hair contest
because I think that's equally as
asinine as eating too much food and I
Texas women really do salute the why do
when you can overdo
so I'm slightly jealous take pictures
yeah we're gonna be here with what looks
like through Labor Day weekend so I'm
gonna try to get to a cowboy preseason
game just so you have it the insanity I
want to see that Stadium obviously the
interior because to me every time I see
it I just want to go once because ever
let's see it I always felt like why the
screen is so big I just might as well
watch it my living room it doesn't seem
like unless you're physically on the
field you have seats worth worrying
about yeah I know it's it I just like a
friend of mine I work with like to these
awesome producer dudes and one's gay and
one straight so i get i get both fixes
but when I came on board one of the
dudes is like oh my god I'm like dying
the dog sports no one talks sports I was
like oh god well it's your lucky day so
we plan to go to a cowboy a cowboy
preseason game but what I am even more
excited about because honestly you know
how much I can't stand the Cowboys I am
very excited to go see a texas rangers
game i want to go see that ballpark me
too okay you're have to like it snapchat
maybe you're not on snapchat what am I
will get on snapchat just to whatever
that means nah I'll walk her through in
America don't worry it'll be long
tutorials but we'll get it done can't
say I've ever lifted a piloting
microphone to drink coffee in the middle
of a process I have no idea what this is
even gonna sound like people we did a
test run yes last night it took us like
40 minutes to figure out how to turn on
skype so this is going to work but if
the audio is off it will get better I
mean I think allegedly allegedly the
audio might get better so just bear with
us first of all huge shout-out to all
things comedy we're usually in the
studio so I can see it plastered all
around but they love to you yes to be so
supportive to us and in the words of
erin go cards Oh Lord well I used to
give him a shout out that's very sweet
Erin we love you and miss you and God
knows we wish you were engineering this
skype call
I the fact that i have to like look at
volume bars and try to figure I mean
let's just say I just did wake up though
because technology when i'm in charge of
technology in any way shape or form I
feel like I i I just I slept for like 20
minutes and I was like what is this guy
too does it work what if i plug it in it
but I was up half the night worrying
about text which is why I'm so thankful
to record in all things comedy studio
but I also felt like it was Christmas
morning they get up and talk sports with
you so the same way let's get in it
let's do this can we briefly just I'm
gonna glaze over this for everybody the
cab's the Cavs can well that's the story
wanted to kick off ok will do NBA first
and then we'll get into all kinds of
stuff and we're going to end on a sweet
feel-good moment of the week that kicks
off what I think is like now kicking off
the Olympics I'm getting so excited
about the Olympics now that I figured
out my ATT uverse or whatever ttv all
right now that I know I can tape stuff
I'm gonna be like oh D and do you love
that you say type stuff oh yes I'm gonna
I'm gonna say my VHS I just figured it
out that's the Marion dick Foley in you
and off it is it is because they say
tape stuff all the time I almost bought
I spent two hundred forty dollars in
target yesterday don't I probably about
the one thing that you went for ya uh
something for my hair i am but i did buy
of course Yahtzee and half the sports
section I was like do I need like three
footballs in a yoga mat all right I
can't even send ridiculous but one thing
i bought this is like yoga package
because my back hurts and i hate yoga
and i was like i guess i could do it
with like a DVD I don't even have a DVD
player I haven't I vedere I've a mac air
no DVD attachment and then I went and
then I came back to this house that I'm
staying at no TV I'm like okay I don't
even forget it this makes my whole day
you know there's entire i'll send you
links to workout videos and money so it
Trish I honestly thought I think people
do this online and I'm literally from
like 1980 i I'm my tech is whatever it's
awesome i love it
since I have spoken to you your
household the Gauss Holt has changed
your marriage has changed join us about
how the Cleveland Cavaliers are
champions in your Cleveland households
it's a different it's been a very big
deal um I was at a town I was working in
vegas on Game seven and which are you
know good or bad I felt it big to be
good to not be home so it just so
happened which was Father's Day and I
was in a town working and I was working
with three women who don't like sports
oh my god oh my god okay so having a lot
of things done and I was like ladies
okay game time game time thank the card
that couldn't get me to a sports book
because it's Las Vegas on a game day
it's gonna be on every screen um Nene
couldn't couldn't get anywhere near one
and finally I just had that flip out
where I was like I have to leave you
people I'm sorry this is a life-changing
moment and I had no service to text my
husband where I want huh so finally I
get on the casino floor and I'm standing
everything looking between the willow
fortune monitors and I didn't ravali had
a did you know dolly parton had a slot
machine things I need to go back and
investigate just give me a monitor I
don't even know what's happening and as
I am walking past the sports book I see
the championship hat go on LeBron and my
husband is texting we want and I'm like
oh excited and like elated and then sad
because i missed it and I called him and
he's like hoarse from screaming just the
horse and it was so awesome and clearly
up we've watched it a few times cuz I
don't know if you're aware but you can
purchase a in a game but officially 87
on itunes and my husband watches it
every night on his little mobile device
like it's a bedtime story and it's the
sweetest thing y'all
it will be what what many a Cleveland
Fan will tuck their baby into bed with
for generations to come it was like aunt
goo dolls like what are you doing he
said my his computer he says headset on
and like what are you doing he's just
giggling I'm thinking he's watching a
cat video and I copay but I wave my hand
and he pops is everybody on the way
doing this fourth quarter game seven so
good this is amazing it is y'all I'm
gonna try to get him on snapped he hates
snapchat so he followed me on snapchat
it is worth the watch because how much
he watches it I can't really put it into
art but he's like like he's got it for
life and it's like a little security
blanket and he's joyful so I get it you
know I feel that way about many a
Kentucky win over the years but is the
cutest thing because it's been so long
so we are a very happy Cleveland
household and personally the tribe is
trying to do something you know trying
to get in the game to Cleveland although
the Indians have been on fire I get out
Chisenhall for the peaches they are they
not just I'm very impressed with them
let's just I'm listen you know my my
sweet spot of Cleveland I bore my cat I
were Mike Lee I you know technically its
grounds but it's just a big sea on it
which I I don't cheer for the Browns but
I'm i bought it because it's just it
reminds me of Cleveland because you know
I met my lady there and it's such a
sweet city it was I tell you that we had
reappear on a couple weeks ago he was
born in Akron ah that's my husband grew
up right around the corner yeah so I
should have I mean she she I was a kid
you want to call it and she called in
and I just SAT there for like I don't
know 15 20 minutes and let her scream
into the mic it was the cutest thing
ever she was like you know what I was
like just run with go just just get it
out yeah awesome what was really funny
was the mass um everyone we knew trying
to get a newspaper of some kind of any
kind that's a Cleveland one from
Cleveland
It was as if like my husband was like
custom his parents like listen he's a
gone cuz I like they're not sports fans
it's the weirdest thing um we both are
like I don't get in by the way not a
sports fan it's like I don't know what
happened there meanwhile my brother and
I like breathe it but uh they were like
well we tried to go grocery stores sorry
one two capes and early huh but his town
he grew up in is just right outside of
Akron can't they yeah it was it was fun
and adamant you know wasn't gonna it was
uh yeah I was really I was thinking
about you guys and you know it was just
the whole thing it was like seven games
of me being torn but at the at the very
end I was just like they that it was
they wanted it more if we go back to my
predictions I believe I said Cleveland
and seven I don't remember when
Cleveland and seven Courtney said
sacrament a Golden State and seven I
said I and then I became Switzerland yes
you did I said I think I think Golden
State and seven and then I screamed out
cabs in seven but I honestly had no idea
and I was betting I would have bet on
the Warriors I I was like you know what
you just see in somebody's eyes and at
the end of game 6 I said to my husband I
was like let me tell you something I was
like there's something him right now Pam
meeting LeBron yeah and him right now
that is its and I'm gonna cross I so
weird yeah it's it was so and I hate to
be like it was so much bigger than him
cuz people are like bull crap but it was
that was yeah I don't think we'll have
those moments and you and I've been
talking about this so much with
everything else going on with the NBA I
don't think cuz we know of clearly
LeBron is not a franchise player but I
think there's so much he shouldered so
much of what he caused initially by not
staying and being a franchise player um
that he he bore a bigger burden on
himself than even the city put on him I
know that sounds very esoteric and like
I've been watching a lot of Oprah but
truly I believe he wore that more than
the city put on I think oh I I mean I
have never I mean how much worse if I
watched my life every 20 minutes like be
honest set all day and practically all
night where people just keep talking
about television
like which is fine because it's a TV
show right so it's like this show on
this show they're like right Erin and
I'm like yeah like I haven't watched I'm
I'm like in an entertainment job and I
completely lost like I you know if it's
I think how much like a couple of shows
you know it's not but i live i live in a
cave but my my TV show is sports right
so and you know there's only a couple
people that give a crap so on this
particular job that I'm doing so
everyone's like have you seen that job
and I was just like oh so the amount of
sports I've watched it's comparable to
all their television um but I don't
think I've seen in ending where people
were sobbing like I literally just tears
pour I mean I literally was like I mean
of course I was crying but I I cry you
know when someone hits a free throw but
III just was like oh my god and I was so
and I you know I'm not a cabs fan per se
but like I was just so happy but I don't
think I've ever you see people welling
up and and crying a little but oh my it
was a sob fest I think people were girls
how people feel about LeBron people as a
whole yeah just you know I'd also think
that draymond greens behavior with other
players kind of soured um you know like
the you know cheap shots on the junk and
all that kind of SAT bird the sweet
little like bubble that Golden State had
because it just looked like bad
schoolyard you know brats so I think
those little moments made people go wait
a minute they're not as shiny and golden
as we all thought they were and so then
all of a sudden this paradigm shift
happened where people were like you know
what who cares miss LeBron did that damn
City mate yeah it was really the city it
was a city and something above them yeah
it was awesome yakkung of a draymond
Green yeah how about that listen uh if
you don't know the story apparently he
just got um yeah well whatever help he's
not going to the jail or anything I mean
he just got a ticket tech
arrested technically but it was probably
like hey can you come down here and he's
like it got into a an altercation after
being like heckled or whatever and he
slapped him or punched him / Asterix
scroll down I'm dying to know if he
kicked him in the groin because he
kicked the other guy in the groin then
we full-on have evidence that he's got a
groin the problem he's got it I want I
want this story to come out that he
kicked that dude in the groin on
platelet I system or bedam or something
I want it to be growing related so bad
he's such a schoolyard like he seems
like the kid it was like oh no kick by I
like at one of your life really you're
grown you're a grown man yeah it's and
he's so fun to watch and I am a huge I'm
a huge fan of his but um even from
watching him at Michigan State like I
love that dude but uh yeah those um I
felt like eight kids were so crazy yeah
I felt like it tainted the shiny Natalie
totally how like you look we're just one
team and we rise above I like not really
cuz that's not right about behavior just
so we're all it was okay it was cheesy
um a couple more NBA stuff and then
we'll then we'll keep it moving um when
we spoke yesterday on the phone we
almost couldn't even speak about this
because I wanted to throw myself off the
balcony and you were driving and almost
took your car and careened it off the
Malibu highway Kevin Durant to the
Warriors I can't Kevin Durant to the
Warriors I mean I can't I don't even I
was so angry I don't know where I was I
think I was I guess I was here working I
can't remember where I was I couldn't
like I I saw the screen of my phone on
the ESPN app and it had Durant to the
Warriors right after we got a report a
couple days ago before that was like
Durant looks like he's saying I was like
of course he should i just had full
confidence that he was going to stay
wait we all did and when it happened my
husband i just kept walking around the
house like you know what somebody
had sold our identity where'd you look
on our face like yeah well we should put
better passwords on it well like we just
we were you doing this awesome at each
other and if ya ween we knew we were
protected yet at the same time it got
taken from the group someone took my cat
someone took my cat that one I mean is
he microchip getting back like
everyone's fun it was such a weird
moment because and you and I just had
this conversation yesterday sorry y'all
we had a lot of sports to catch up on
yesterday and then we were like quit
talking because when you do it on the
show um he rip I really believed he kind
of was the last of the new era if you
will the franchise players we know that
Kobe in Tim Duncan and Dirk Nowitzki all
the Dwyane Wade will have that one
minute that would that was kind of at
the one step back of a franchise player
this kevin durant was the New Era's yeah
only real franchise player and I guess
we could say the same is steph curry but
i have a feeling we might you know lose
him down the road to him ring in a
paycheck so I'm not nobody's ruled out
because Kevin Durant again represented a
bigger thing who knows this might be
part of the NBA drama that's I swear
turning into the WWE where he's gonna
leave and then come back because I just
blowed it Oklahoma's I honestly think um
now obviously you know I know I'm gonna
get like you know there's articles
already like you know don't blame during
Philippa blah here's we're on the same
page with this but just you know and I
think Barkley had a really great video
of him saying you can have a wonderful
happy kick ass NBA career without
winning a championship it happens to
about eighty percent of the people that
play in the NBA and so skipping skipping
out of a team that has built everything
around you yes right to go to a team
like the worry
years that you think it's it like you're
just going to plug in and win a
championship like I get it right I get
it Durant just wants to win a
championship however it's just it Mike
it makes him again so unlikable and also
another thing is like for me I can only
speak for myself but Oklahoma City
almost beat Golden State like they came
within you know five rocks points they
gave that game up yeah that they should
have beaten Golden State right yeah and
you've got a team with Billy Donovan a
brand new coach who solidified that team
I mean Scott Brooks did a great did a
great job but then they get rid of Scott
Brooks the next time bill jaaneman comes
in on this first season and takes you
two with a couple of baskets of getting
to the NBA Finals they've got waiters
they've got Westbrook they're they're
committed the city's committed fans are
committed the new coach everything is
like in your pocket to win and to create
to create this team you know of the
future and you just flat-out bail on a
one-year deal III was I was sick to my
stomach because it's the NBA autumn it
just takes such a huge hit the NBA just
takes such a huge hit because then you
plug in then it becomes a supergroup
then it becomes bosh wade and lebron and
miami and you automatically hate miami
like right now the thought of of
cheering from a sweet my sweet warriors
I'm like oh it's a super team I and now
and now I really have no interest in
cheering for the Warriors except for and
because and I really love that scrappy
you know just kind of developing this
team over time and now it's plug and
play and I hate it I hate it it's an for
this problem with Wade going to Chicago
because it's the end of his career and
it got messy and he's Enys she's from
Chicago and he won his champion like out
to me I'm like you know you want I guess
just as a fan
I can't speak to what it's like to be a
player obviously but like you just want
these teams to stay intact and end up to
play for so you know the identities of
these teams so you can really create a
fan base and really be like oh I like
that team that team has been together
forever well I think you said something
really great yesterday about your
respect level for the Lakers yes yeah I
thought that was such a great statement
because you know the Lakers or the
lakers and they are not used to losing
and when they realized even though they
were going to be a basically a shitshow
the next five to seven years like there
were a world where like you said they
paid what Cody Kobe 80 million I don't I
can't even remember the number it was so
everybody's million-dollar bonus it was
itself was something like a baby arm and
a clef foot or whatever I just made that
up as you see release yesterday that
they're pregnant Kobe's pregnant that'll
be just like you're pregnant it's a baby
mama and I was like does that mean she's
having a ball wait yeah hold on it was
on ESPN on Instagram you're never on
your instrument i bet they I know I
really I really I have a long list of
things to do at social media um so I bet
that I bet I I bet it was a baby
conceived on his last game you know it
says baby Mamba hold on let me pull it
up it says there's a baby mama on the
way via Kobe Bryant now if we use my fur
just so random that he shags whatever
i'm sure people said that it's just
beyond blessed and excited to share that
we were expecting our third baby girl
baby girl another baby girl oh my God
he's like I just want a boy let's keep
doing this that's cute that's cute I
love babies but yeah i was thinking like
God the Lakers just want Kobe to finish
out his career as he should as a Laker
and they threw him way too much money
but they throw him the money to stay and
I thought well but the thing is I don't
think it came down to money with Duran I
think they would have paid him anything
quite frankly uh you know I yeah I'm
with you I think he feels like I think
those guys get this weird ticking clock
Bob where they're like
I have to have X amount of titles under
my belt for what they do and i'm with
you i think it was short sightedness as
close as they have come and this year's
been as close as it's ever end in my
opinion they threw it away when you
watch if you go back and watch those
games against Golden State they HAMP
they literally hand at Golden State the
finals because it was ok see they
imploded and you know yeah I guess what
I don't know obviously what we don't
know is maybe Kevin Durant um was super
unhappy maybe he hates Westbrook maybe
he didn't get a lot of Billy Donovan
maybe waiters is a prima donna maybe the
team dynamic he just did not like so of
course you know if you're that unhappy
you leave I just don't feel my gut is
like I'm gonna bail cuz I want to win
yeah and i think you're right i think
they have to like win multiple times so
they can be in like hall of fame what
like it's just the egos I think it's all
ego and it just makes me and now it just
feels like a total imbalance of power
and now I'm like uh just and you know
Adam Silver obviously was not happy with
it he came out like not happy and then
then they're kind of reeling I was just
saying to you this morning that um they
they have now corrected the hack-a-shaq
rule uh so if we don't blame that to me
what's going on there I'm I knew they
had to do something because it was
getting so bad it was getting so bad a
you know where they fouled the big man
who can't shoot free throws away from
the ball so he has to shoot free throws
so he misses and they get the ball back
you some so what well the rule right now
is in the last two minutes of a quarter
if you if you hack them then I think
it's like they have one shot and you get
the ball back so now they're
implementing that in every quarter I
think it was just like the last two
minutes of the game or something so now
it's going to be every single quarter
with last two minutes if you foul a big
man off of
ball intentional internationally an
intentional foul you get the ball back
you get at least one foul shot if not to
file Joe foul shots I guess it's like
you know whatever that number is I think
it's after seven you get two fouls like
in a normal game or whatever you meaning
the team that gets hacked gets the back
yeah and then you get the ball back so
it's it's it's like in like almost like
a flagrant foul where you get the ball
back so it becomes a deterrent to
starting a whole hacker process yes
which I it's it's weird that you have to
do that it's weird that this whole thing
just happened in in in basketball and I
hate policing the game in anything away
because big men should learn how to
shoot a free throw so part of me hates
it but also part of me likes it because
it was awful and slow down the game and
it sucked all they did was just hack and
hack and hack and it just it makes the
game shitty so I'm torn but i guess i'll
go with they needed to do something they
really call me Trish they did not call
me anything so it's him I know it's just
not fair we need to have like mystery
science 3000 theater you need to have
for all sports like you could choose to
turn us on or just watch the
commentators come on we would kill it
alright so let's just leave with Duncan
and then walk over to other stuff but I
I have to say my my journey with Tim
Duncan has come full circle uh I never
liked him and then yeah never liked him
never fan and in the last I don't know
four or five years I've become a super
fan of Tim Duncan oh it may have shed a
lot of tears i already posted on the
sports without balls facebook page this
morning the gregg popovich inner
basically interview he came outside of
the whatever practice court and gave a
little rare interview for Popovich and
talked about Tim Duncan because he's
like because I know Tim Duncan wouldn't
because that's Tim Duncan and did I have
tears streaming down my face I did I did
in Popovich Gregg Popovich may
me cry that last sweet that's how sweet
it was sad to watch it it's so sweet uh
he was he literally gregg popovich gets
choked up ah that mean it's just worth
the watch because if you don't if you if
you're not fans of the show if you're
not super familiar with Gregg Popovich
the coach of the Spurs you know my dream
is always to have like a Popovich Bill
Belichick stare off because they both
give two words after every single
interview and you're just like oh he's
just like they'll go up to Gregg
Popovich after like the obligatory first
or second quarter and they're like you
know you're done by 10 what are you
thinking you know you need in he's like
get it in the hoop and he walks away
like he's just notoriously like he
doesn't give a [ __ ] and he does the most
asinine yet toddler like answers it's
what's so great about him he explains it
to like a general every time you pick up
the ball and you put it in the hoop and
that's my vision and at first it's so
off-putting and then you just like I
just I I can't even tell you I don't
think there's been a team or a coach in
sports that I am now more on board of
bored with that I was just Popovich I
was like blah Duncan law there's a dead
body under his porch like I just was
typed out by Duncan from day one and now
I love him so much and when he want when
they want it like 23 years ago his kid
just just sobbing he's hopping I gave
Aaron my nerdy fast fact that since 1997
and that Tim Duncan came into the NBA
they have made the playoffs every single
year of his career that's a pretty
powerful not every single year Tim
Duncan's me the playoffs yes that's for
19 years the man has made the play that
tells you what an athlete and I'm not
saying he did it alone but obviously
just how special he and pops
relationship was I mean and think about
it I mean he slipped through the Admiral
David Robinson president and when you
think about the just the span of time I
mean my gosh he's I was you know I was
in
school yeah college which I'm yeah an
adult with Tim time like we always joke
e63 and in the NBA but yeah I like I've
done my life with me yeah he's just his
body of work is so impressive that fact
that he was a spur the whole time is so
probably my favorite thing um and if or
if you remember you know those Spurs
teams with the Admiral were so good but
they never one now and then Tim Duncan
comes on board I think he was from maybe
van and he was at Vanderbilt animal yeah
I want to sandra and uh comes on the
court and then that they start winning
and then Ginobili in part I just those
teams were and you know some of those
years I didn't cheer for those teams
because they won all the time and it was
I got it got so old but i definitely
fell in love with the Spurs the first
year they played the heat or the second
year to play the heat and I was like oh
my god they play so hard they love it so
much Tim Duncan doesn't stop Tim Duncan
is like the he's like the Bruce
Springsteen of music because I saw Bruce
I waited my whole life to see bruise I
finally saw Bruce at the garden it was a
three hour show and Bruce Springsteen
did not leave the stage his all band
left the stage people in and out fans
left the garden get a beer goat Bruce
Springsteen did not leave the stage and
when I was watching Tim got Duncan when
he wins or loses or whatever he'd every
single play he plays with a hundred
percent yes that's very well said
absolutely I mean he's just he's another
era coached by a coach from another era
yeah and you and I said yesterday really
I feel like he may be dirt in the
whiskey would be our last one I'm trying
to think of anything else that will be
our franchise players that wait watch
because Dirk Nowitzki's at 18 years and
even you know Mark Cuban posted a really
sweet thing yesterday he said I'm you
know proud of everything that you've
done and I'm just sad that you didn't
give us a year to give you a full send
off as you deserve yeah he's like
because we would have loved to have
celebrated you in dallas and he's like
we'll do it anyway but we would have
looked and it on the core
and I thought that that's the kind of
player that you know that everybody
universally was like you have to be that
kind of respect to give you your
farewell tour and what a class act he
didn't want that clearly he's just he
did everything right it was just so yeah
he will be missed for sure so I almost
literally almost I hope she said r.i.p
didn't what I meant was happy retirement
Tim Duncan wow that got weird real quick
oh I'm anyway alright so I NBA put to
bed until another season until another
season uh summer right now which you
know it's a whole nother rodeo I should
have gone my uncle said did you want to
come out for summer league I had too
much going on I think next year y'all
you and I might need to do summer league
right but what I want to do most of all
is a baseball preseason uh yeah she's
called spring training wow I am like I
am like a good 30 seconds behind my
brain that's what I want to do that's
I'm dying to do that okay let's do it
cuz my husband goes every year and then
I'm always like oh yeah we need to do
spring training also you know what I
realized a WNBA which the season is
already kicking ass i am in dallas and i
forgot well i just landed here a week
ago that Tulsa the Tulsa Shock moved out
of tulsa to dallas and it's the dallas
wings which is crazy because every menu
has so much goddamn chicken wings on
these menus i like a chicken what I like
a second what it might be like like
because there's two airports in dallas
and maybe they meant it that way but i
bet they could I bet it's I'm gonna
start calling at the Dallas tricking
ways WNBA I in my backyard so I'm gonna
go see the Dallas ladies play which I'm
super excited about and so I've got Lee
I've got some two months sports goals
while I'm here and went on earth we've
got the Rangers and then I've got the
Dallas a WNBA team
and then he'd be a preseason cow also
Houston is only like four or five hours
away so and I have like we have a shared
car so i'm thinking i have like it up
like a Tuesday Wednesday type of
schedule off so I'm thinking if the
Houston Astros are playing I'm just
gonna do like a crazy road trip when you
you know astros tickets unfortunately
are reasonable so you could probably get
dugout club for a $25 and still bad boy
they took a run last season in this
season not so much but yeah it's the gas
money will even out the out you know
dugout see actually perfect yet
Houston's only four hours away some of
that that is in my wheelhouse also the
summer grabbing I mean when am I going
to be a wait like four hours away from
Houston unless I'm in Houston performing
but I just thought road trip why not
yeah those are my summer sports plans um
all right let's do a little peaches
update will do a little MLB and I just
tell fans at home this is what i get
yesterday i get an email and I get it
tech than an email from here that just
says phil is back you guys bill is back
and already haunting me this season I
new fans of the show I real quick recap
my fantasy baseball team is it Rockford
peaches the peaches started out on fire
I was in first place for nine weeks in
thing and now I have been actively
dropping every single week because the
peaches here's what I want to happen I
want to in a perfect world I want to get
a conference call with all my pages I
want to get I gotta get a conference car
with my peaches and like hit the effing
ball by pitching is so much better I had
a real pitching problem the beginning of
the season and now no one can hit a
freakin ball to save their life it
happening that is bad collectively all
the
each's are taking shits on the field
don't you feel like though this it's
always this too weird slump during the
like right at the all-star I always feel
like at the all-star break everybody
just kind of Jack's it up for lack of a
better one well uh I'll tell you the new
roster because you won't recognize half
of it because I've been wheeling and
dealing like a fill in the blank with
some sort of pun Vegas dealer I don't
know all right here's my team okay so
and then we have to I'll tell you really
quick about the return of Phil because I
sent you that email um right okay so
you're I apologize in advance my two
Dodger pickups I don't think we've even
talked about this you got rid of Turner
I got rid of Turner the week after
Turner decides to start playing baseball
I know it as soon as you send me that
I'm on fire Trish and if someone picked
him up cuz he's on fire so Justin Turner
so annoyed by him grand all just I don't
know what happened but last week he hit
like six home runs in a row yes okay my
eye is back on him but he is just not
he's just not having it this season so
every catcher was picked up so I'm still
sticking with weeders from Baltimore but
it's not like he's doing great Trumbo so
good rend own from the Washington
Nationals and I picked up Escobar now
let me tell you you know Yunel Escobar
was a peach last season and consistently
did well I probably should have picked
him up but he also had some homophobic
slurs two seasons ago so he's not my
favorite he did apologize I'm gonna
pretend it didn't happen because I need
runs okay I Nick listen here and eggs
listen Trisha we all know they're all
pigs ah i pick victim i was drinking
coffee alla alla moment of gap of air
okay um i don't want to know anything
about it because they're all guys is
appointment I I picked up didi Gregorius
my shortstop for the Yankees because
he's been also in the last couple weeks
he's been on fire
her a Machado my love my love ah he'll
be a peace forever I picked up David
Freese temporarily yeah all new Hayward
i'm sticking with because trish let me
just discuss really quickly Jason
Heyward I I he was my first pick he was
my first pick can I just tell you he's
having the worst season of all seasons
and any other player I would have
dropped him because he's I call him my
albatross he's the peaches albatross
filling me Trish every single day so
much so that i've been benching him and
I picked him up first round you wanna
maybe you should get on a conference
call with him if I could call one person
Trish I'd call jason heyward and Billy
get your [ __ ] together let me just tell
you this a couple weeks ago Hayward goes
he has a little come to Jesus moment
with a Joe Maddon coach of the Cubs
right and he says there's all these new
guys the Cubs have been you know just
actively there's been some injuries and
they've called up a whole bunch of
players right he goes to mad and sits
mad and down and says if you need
because there's all these new guys if
you need to drop me in the order because
haywards being a batting second right
after my sweet boy that I had all last
year that I love that I that I didn't F
extra Fowler owler yeah so Fowler's
hitting first haywards heading second
and just crapping the bed every single
game since opening day goes to madden
and says listen I know there's all these
new guys if you need experience feel
free to drop me down in the order I'm
gonna put this mic away from my mouth
for a sec real quick of course you're
gonna drop yourself down in the order
cuz you suck you stink okay I'm back I
feel like he disguised it with like you
know listen I've ixnay Hayward's like
I've experienced don't worry you can
drop me down in the order you can drop
me down the or because I can't hit a
breaking ball so now he's hitting six
you know I picked him up because he was
hitting second right in front of Rizzo
and Chris Brian so that means hits and
runs
now he's hitting six which is like and
you know who also got moved down to six
rend own so two of my first five picks
are now hitting sixth and seventh god I
want them on the phone I want them on
the phone I'm gonna have to make a call
um here's the associate general man you
are the associate general manager Hosmer
has been a dream actress scroll down MVP
of last night's all-star game Hosmer MVP
of the game last night awesome here's a
cute story I don't fed if you guys have
their just I just saw I saw highlights
and then I saw Hosmer speaking as he won
the MVP and the Royal hasn't been MVP of
the all-star game since bo jackson and I
love love Hosmer he's been a killer
peach he said last night that Miggy
Miguel Cabrera uh world's greatest first
baseman right now Indy and the MLB and
his first base yeah let Hosmer bat for
him and was like go up get your third
at-bat because he already drove in like
one run and then hit a home run so that
could like kind of secure him MVP and he
thanked him i welled up last night I did
have a couple of / but yes isn't that
awesome that's being of course it is
it's beyond awesome that's what we love
sports those moments right there so
great isn't that so great and like such
like the heart of what like an all-star
game should be about and just a side
note asterisks fro down reasons I love
that MLB all-star game is it means
something they decide is decides the
World Series home field advantage and I
believe all all-star games I don't even
know why we do the NFL but anyhow just
so the players can go to Hawaii and be
hot mess but I feel like it should all
have meaning and I think it'd be worth
something and I think that's why i love
the MLB so much more than hands down it
is the best all-star game yep because of
steaks because steaks I mean the NBA is
kind of fun because it's just like no
one plays defense since 182 189
but it but it was a care at home court
advantage regardless of how you played
it'd be so much better it would be nuts
it'd be nice be nice anyways most of the
pitching is remain the same with the
peaches who I did pick up who I think
could really help why pictures and haul
from the Indians now he's really streaky
so we'll see i'm super young but great
Chuck of Aaron st. Louis Cardinals he's
only in his maybe second or third year
he got picked up pretty quickly in the
draft he's had a crappy year they sent
him down to triple-a but I always had
like you know my radar on him a couple
injuries to a couple cards players he
just got a promoted back up to the bigs
and I thought I should just grab him
just in case and it's only been a week
now because now we have this break with
the all-star game and he hit he bit he
hit hbu it beautifully so I'm hoping
Chisenhall in gray check breathes some
I'm hoping for some second half of the
season magic yeah because my pitching is
shored up but my batting has been a word
you don't want to use anemic oh yeah ye
all right let's talk about Phil
fire-sale real quick don't tennis maybe
some tennis and Olympics I Phil I'll
make this real quick because it fans of
the show know who Phil is Phil is my
arch enemy everybody's archenemy he's
been a messy he's the Newman yes Trish
NIM no oh hell yeah the basement Phil
stole Noah syndergaard from my from my
peaches lineup it's too long historic
you can go back into the episodes and
find it but feels like a real a-hole
thorn in everybody side so apparently
what's been happening with Phil is he
didn't draft well his pitching stinks
he's in the lower third of this season
and decides to basically bail he's in
his basement like you said
steer his in his basement reading
everything 24 hours a day and whenever a
hot young player gets called up you just
automatically you don't even have time
to get him because fells already taken
him he will take players that are
playing well in double-a sit him on his
bench so whatever he's psycho but so
he's still going to be in it because
he's got all these guys that no one even
knows like it's like it's on the message
boards it was like his team picked up
blah blah blah and you're like who the
hell is that dude and you have to google
the dude and you're like sensation out
of Puerto Rico you're like I don't even
whatever I don't even care so he
basically put a note to all these to
everybody and that was like um listen
you know i hears players up for grabs
for future picks for next year's draft
then sent me a private message because i
guess he likes some players on my team
and he just thinks it like I don't know
like I'm dumb I you know I'm young to
this quote unquote fantasy baseball and
I'm playing him this weekend and all
next week unfortunately and he's like
years he probably knows my bad ANC's
crap uh he's like he sent me like four
or five players he's like if you wanna
you know trade for pics or bubble blah
like up my butt and I was like oh Phil
the return of fill your return of Phil
and then he said these this weekend and
next week boat cuz we're playing 10 days
in a row is like well I remember our
epic battle from last season like a
douche burger I'm not giving you any one
hello even if it would help me I'm not
I'm not I am NOT I'm not make me so
happy oh that you completely avoided
Phil's fire sale I love it sorry y'all I
had to do that sidebar real quick it's
it's just like no yeah I know some
players on this team can hit but you
know what I believe in my pate peaches I
also working 80 jobs and I'll have time
to research your roster and for future
trade boobs well it's good to be filling
the basement I guess I I mean listen
whatever gets you through the day I
guess
um so I'll keep everybody posted on the
peaches what do you think about the
second season of the Dodgers before we
move on from baseball you know we if we
get a healthy Kershaw back your pen is
still what so what does Aaron Aaron
knows normally she and I both literally
been working our IT jobs normally I'm at
the ballpark you know at least twice a
week I'm gonna say these words out loud
everybody I've been once all season and
I feel like I'm gonna be put on Dodger
probation um that they're gonna want
some kind of you know ID for me to have
a Dodger dog oh I just don't feel like
the team feels like I'm supporting them
so i have to write that ship as we come
out of the all-star break because i
can't be the weak link can't you are the
glue that holds the Dodgers together
Trish so you gotta figure out how to get
to the stadium I'm gonna just make it
happen I want her shawl back healthy I
love our sweet corey seager thrilled
that he made it to the all-star game
this year being stomped the home run
derby of course Trumbo you're welcome it
was great and then of course we all know
i mean the gin I look he he's so good
it's like a cyborg he is he's like oh he
doesn't look real he literally looks
like a baseball action figure yeah get
him you're like i just sit there with a
head tilt like are you like lebron is to
basketball that is Giancarlo it's just
that it's yeah okay first of all I
thought his name I thought they were
Butchie butchering my Spanish name but
it's like it's basically like john carlo
you guys my husband's text in making the
living room because he heard the
question that Aaron asked what do we
want for the second half smart gonna
jump on and say yeah he says get
starters back and stay the course yes
Dave yes get starters back and stay the
course and you've got my sweet Yankee
Brandon McCarthy he's back he looks good
is I know I hope let me text him inside
he has to come in and say something real
quick I'm like I've got to go to work
and my husband's in there Oh bolt +
bullpen is doing well so don't say that
they're not good oh ok so we've got Dave
in the outskirts of the house chiming in
about the Dodgers which
amazing which is bonus a teacher said
I'm not coming in right now well I know
Dave can hear me tell him to get on
we're gonna be skyping from your house
Dave so get out you have to get on at
some point well at my babe just let you
know cuz I know you're listening I
probably got your door with a glass we
are no one's gonna physically see this
they would only hear your voice yeah
it's all it's all audio it's a call when
here in and out look like right now
please America needs to know about I
look like a some sort of teenage lady
pilot on our first day what's that with
a vision problem so it's it's going to
be good tennis a quick NFL shout out and
then feel-good moment of the week and I
know I realize it's been two weeks and
there's so many more sports so I'm gonna
try to get to everything these next
couple weeks I might have to double up
per week but we didn't even I didn't
even talk about the French Open uh in
muguruza one and she's one of my
favorite up-and-coming players be
beating Serena then we go into wimbleton
and I realized that for all this
dominance of serena she hadn't won a
major since last wimbleton which was
hard to get your head around she gets
beat by muga Ruth in the French she gets
beat by Kerber in the Australian Open
which i'm going to say for years to come
if if if some person if you're a sports
fan in your lady tennis fan and someone
goes I don't think they will because I
think women's tennis obviously is just
reach another level of absolutely
outstanding but if some douchebag
trapped you in a small corner first of
all run but if they drive you to smoke
order and they're like women's tennis is
blah blah blah say okay d-bag watch the
women's Australian final of 2016 between
Angelique Kerber and Serena Williams one
of the best matches I will ever see uh
and so this year's wimbleton was Kerber
playing serene around two wimbleton
ladies final and i only watch the first
set because i didn't realize i could
record but i got the first set in before
i went to work on saturday morning again
another amazing match and Kerber had
beat venus in this
emmys it was in the first of all huge
congratulations to Venus Williams are
getting through the sem ease of
wimbleton this year she stepped up her
game and Serena and Venus one another
doubles and Serena one number 22 in ties
Steffi Graf and by the way won her first
17 years ago at the US open against
Steffi Graf I am a stat nerd today my
god Trish that's all so much Irene oh
that that's so cool at 17 years old that
there you go at 17 years old and because
I've only probably done it twice in a
hundred and thirty five episodes I'm
going to do it one more time for new
listeners and because it's the greatest
one of the greatest moments in female in
in tennis and Lady tennis uh was when
just some random match I couldn't even
tell you maybe it was the finals I don't
even know where it was god knows how
long ago Steffi Graf became human in my
eyes she goes to serve and someone
screams out steffey will you marry me
and Steffi Graf paused and said how much
money do you have no yes it happened I
saw it's one of the greatest moments of
me watching tennis yeah and I was like
oh my god saya graph has a personality I
have to because I've always disliked her
even when she married my andre agassi
because that was my childhood crush with
unpretty complete with mullet judge me
later um I i have always disliked her
idem na i believe she was the reason my
sweet Monica Seles got shanked that was
that was the one of the most tragic if
not tragic moments in sports I will
never forget it i watched it libels most
awful thing I'm scarred to life but I
pulled up the picture of the other day
of Venus beating Stephie and she just
had that awful sour puss yeah it's just
just just German Oh unlikable yeah but I
has become so likeable I think Andres
chilled her out she's in here gives like
great interviews like she she still put
like she
is she has come a long way but that all
that much sensation right much money do
you have I have to pull that up we're
going to put that on the page I have to
say that I yeah I mean hopefully I maybe
it's out there and no it's not about
YouTube right oh it was just great by
the way we've reached almost an hour
we're wrapping it up right now when we
haven't even discussed how I bought an
extra ticket and carols with me in
Dallas Wow yeah she's in the pool right
now I she literally was like you're on
your own for this one skype makes me
nervous at a six pack she's chilling out
by the pool she'll be back oh hello in a
couple days ago she's getting a bucket
of chicken wings and making sure you
like seven eat your way through Dallas
I've done and Boots farm and chicken
wings I'm she's eating chicken wings
trecan Boone's Farm and she's by the
pool oh my god she's at the screen she's
at the screen door right now screaming
let me in no Carol you lost your chance
he'll be back next week back next week
Carol rest assured sports without boss
man's Carroll is in Dallas she's in
Dallas I wonder why she won't return my
calls its cuz she got to come with you
and I didn't okay there's so much to
talk about we have to wrap this up also
a huge congratulations to any Andy
Murray uh yeah sure a brit has playing
at the wimpleton spot wimbleton finals I
was so happy for him I was also super
happy for me Loesch I always pronounce
his name wrong right reykjavik right
rank of a cat ran ran pivot right right
the Canadian / Eastern European he's
technically Canadian but he's really
Eastern European I'm a big fan of his
tennis any beat Federer and I know
Federer was that you know the fan
favorite but I think this kid is going
to be around for a long time it was a
three-setter I thought it was going to
be a five-setter I just watched the
highlights i didn't i didn't see it but
Murray was well-spoken after and I can't
imagine when you're playing for the
prime minister also with all that
political nonsense and William and Kate
and he won so congratulations it was a
fun wimbleton and I'm looking forward to
US open for sure yeah and I loved it
jay-z and
a showed up for Serena's win that's
exciting they to beat their well I will
tell you guys total side note randomly
if you are bored or it rains or you're
stuck on a plane there's an a any
documentary right now on for the
documentary Special if you will about
Compton about what created Compton and
please watch it because yes it talks
about you know the everybody's on it
from Anthony Anderson died sku I mean
everybody everybody's online but so
powerful is the Williams sisters because
you all forget in the age of NWA and and
everything else that came up with dr.
direct get the Williams sisters were
literally playing tennis on the city
courts of Compton at that time what's
amazing I'm running it down right now
please watch it you guys in Matthew
Williams their daddy explains why I
moved him there and and um cuz they did
not live there he moved them to the
heart of Compton because he's like I
wanted my girls to know what it felt
like to rise up I mean your ball oh my
god I want it and on it they actually
have the footage of his take he still
doesn't have them just so you got them
in front teeth because teeth knocked out
by gang members because they were like
you aren't gonna basically the old
school gangs of Compton were like the
Taliban they didn't want little girls to
realize they could rise up and he has
tapes match smashed in and he was like
come near here again and we'll take you
out like these are my daughters and
they're going to be something and then
it shows all these gang members that
started coming every day to watch them
practice and you'd see Ganguly getting
chills yeah lined up on the fences and
if anyone anybody never had that moment
of respect that Serena and Venus really
deserved when you watch this to realize
what they came from I'm telling you
right now I'm gonna cry walk it was so
powerful because they really represent
yeah an American dream I mean genuine so
to me with everything going on our
country right now to have her win and 22
slam it off it was that moment of this
is what it looks like to just be better
yeah like that's it and please watch
this shop you get a second because it is
such a good I was shocked I was like
haaa
why is this just like it was like thrown
on I think I was on delta way all right
good I'm on it that's awesome but thank
you for sharing that that's super cool
of course go there you go sorry
everybody quick quick shout out and
we'll do more of this as we approach the
Olympics and I'm so excited that the
Olympics Zika games are right around the
corner it's unfortunate the conditions
and people pulling out but um uh lady
soccer women's soccer you know I'm
obsessed with it uh the roster just came
out no huge surprises I'm gonna post
Heather O'Reilly that was I I knew she
she's she's an alternate she's not on
the starting and I knew that was going
to happen but she posted a class act
amazing letter it's on ESPN W and i'll
post it on the facebook page of how
she's just so excited to be part of the
team and she's just a wonderful human
but the big announcement for me was
megan rapinoe made the team her ACL
surgery is apparently she's doing so
much better and if we can have Rapinoe
in Brazil and and be able to see her
play oh that would be just the most
exciting thing in Hope Solo say if she's
gonna go or not manatees going cash
she's going she has to go she's the best
goalie of all time ah ok to sort of
we're at the feel-good moment the week
oh by the way I shout out if you leave I
free keep always forgetting to mention
this leave a five star review on iTunes
and we will read it on the show I forgot
to buy forgot to pull it up so we're
going to not do it this week but we will
do it next week because we all we both
have to go to work um but go to iTunes
five star review read it on the show and
I will do that next week for sure I did
post this on my Facebook page last week
and we're going to do a quick shout out
to this because it's sort of like a tie
for feel-good moment of the week and I
didn't send this to you so I apologize
Trish but i put it up on the facebook
page sports without balls facebook page
thanks to sonoma stompers two women
Kelsey Whitmore and Stacey p agno are
one step closer to getting a one
in to the show two feet female baseball
players that helped team USA get a gold
medal at last year's Pan Am Games signed
a deal with the Sonoma stompers an
independent baseball team based in
Sonoma California so we're going Trish
we're going the wise in the eight-ball
wine in baseball plays in the Pacific
association of professional baseball
clubs they did be last last week one is
17 is one is 25 the 25 year old went to
a note 2.87 er a and with the team I 15
and two thirds innings in the Pan Am
game she's got a fastball and a knuckle
curve and a slider of course it is um I
am so psyched and Whitmore is going to
Cal State Fullerton and a full softball
scholarship these two I am following
yeah he's down all their information
it's on my it's on this portion without
balls page I will tweet it out and I'm
filing these two ladies I love that I'll
see Whitmore Stacey p agno i hope i'm
pronouncing your name right ah that's
part one a feel-good moment of the week
and also Fox has a new show that's
coming out in September called pitch
about the first you know a fictionalized
version about the first first female
baseball pitcher and that's going to be
on Fox it's called pitch a la moune
Davis style is that with the pretty much
copy that uh okay part to feel good
moment of the week goes to Sydney
McLaughlin gatorade female high school
athlete of the year from New Jersey she
already won that and now she just
qualified a couple of days ago for the
Olympics 400 needle meter hurdles she's
16 she's the youngest to go in 40 years
stop it 400-meter hurdles at a track and
field I the youngest for track and field
obviously I think its youngest for track
and field gymnast go it
six but what's true and if you're a
Chinese gymnast you can go at photograph
yeah um yeah so youngest in track and
field in 40 years that's fantastic and a
couple of the other there's four three
above are for women that have slightly
better scores two of them did not
compete well and so they're not going to
the Olympics so there is an outside
chance that she could medal at the
Olympics at 16 that's bananas uh it was
pretty awesome and and it's this great
video of everyone in her hometown in New
Jersey at a bar screaming when she won
i'm gonna post a video i literally was
like this is so awesome and then there's
all these really cute articles of like
you know ten things you should know
about her going into the olympics and
she kicks ass she's so awesome sydney
mclaughlin feel-good moment of the week
so now we all have to watch for her yeah
infield is one of my favorites going in
Toulon I'm sad you're not gonna be home
cuz I'm gonna have a girl for the gold
party to the opening ceremony oh my god
I can't I cannot whatever I the good
thing is here's the good thing i can
record and i'm in uptown dallas and
there's 8,000 bars and restaurants and
working in walking distance I've already
discovered a kick-out sports bar so I'm
going to be watching it hopefully night
and day ah we are back Trish sports
without balls back back I'm so happy and
I'm so happy we could kick off of this
skype project via dallas and via Los
Angeles with you thank you so much thank
you I'm so excited because now we can be
wherever goodness gracious world we end
up because you and I both are always on
the road so yeah so now this gives us
more freedom to do more episodes
together to kick off to be dark for two
weeks felt horrible topic feels great
but to be back with you and Dave in the
other room giving us Dodger attacks IV I
can't I'm cielo [ __ ] he's kind of like a
lilith from or no wait veera that was
Norm's wife on Cheers that you never
but she always would call and SEGA funny
to stop that's not my god dave is B
reveal is dave mirra McCool everyone out
there enjoy enjoy the sports coming up
we got second half of baseball we got w
mba in full swing I'm pretty psyched to
check out Skylar Diggins in the Dallas
wings oh gosh yeah I carol is going to
come out of the pool and do some
fact-checking we got the Olympics coming
up so on the corner another NFL season
so much going on and of course I will do
more sports for ladies I got a tweet
about a lady golf I just could not
prepare enough but I know there's all
kinds of stuff happening that I always
get my roller derby a shout out from
Canada I will do more of that so we're
at a sports without balls show.com
that's the website you can tweet at me
Erin Foley comic you can tweet at SW of
balls I think sports love balls on
Twitter I Nate swb podcast I have to
look us it's swb pod thank you I just
spaced swb pod is the Twitter more
syllables of Facebook page there's all
kinds of ways to get a hold of us to to
let me and everyone know what more
sports you want to do anyway it's a
little clunky the audio will probably be
a little off but just stay with us it's
going to be a fun summer yeah trash work
and everybody find you pretty much you
can watch me on Hollywood today live so
you can go check your local listings for
Hollywood today live com and and if not
just go to all my social media you guys
is at Trish Suhr s you H R TR is Hsu HR
go hunt me down and then I'll tell you
where I'm at and I'm sure we'll see you
soon cuz I'll be all of the round all
around the world and III the summer hi I
have found my baby it's called the law
of the Los Angeles Dodgers Thank You
Trish as always it was awesome seeing
you and talking sports with you I can i
miss you i miss you too sports without
balls fans have the best week of your
life